perhaps you're a retailer and you need
to predict daily product demand or an
employee at a hotel chain and you need
to predict hotel occupancies for next
season
accurate forecasting is critical for
many Industries such as retail supply
chain energy and finance
for example in the consumer goods domain
improving the accuracy of demand
forecasting by 10 to 20 percent can
reduce inventory by five percent and
increase Revenue by two to three percent
how can you use Cutting Edge
Technologies to improve forecasting
accuracy and build an automated pipeline
Google Cloud can help solve these
challenges with vertex AI forecasting
in the vertex forecasting and time
series and practice course you explore
the theories about time series
forecasting work through an end-to-end
workflow using automl and learn to build
an automated pipeline using vertex AI
this course is designed for data
analysts data scientists and machine
learning Engineers who want to build
end-to-end high performance forecasting
Solutions on Google Cloud
through a series of video lectures
quizzes and Hands-On Labs learn the key
Concepts and the applications of a
sequence model time series and
forecasting
identify the options to develop a
forecasting model on Google Cloud
describe the end-to-end workflow to
develop a forecasting model using vertex
AI
prepare data including ingestion and
feature engineering using bigquery and
vertex managed data sets
train a forecasting model and evaluate
the performance using automl
deploy and monitor a forecasting model
using vertex AI Pipelines
and build a forecasting model from end
to end using a retail data set
this course was developed by Dr yuana
long a technical curriculum developer at
Google Cloud feel free to contact her if
you have any questions or comments
let's get started